let me give you an image it's a cliche
but it's an image John Wayne Oh God
couldn't we start with someone easier
let me ask you a question has John Wayne
ever been at a loss of words seriously
go watch your favorite John Wayne
classic and pay attention to how he
speaks over his 40-year career
regardless of his age character or mood
he almost always talks with the same
iconic masculine confidence and control
he always has the right thing to say and
as few words as possible that'll be the
day even when he's angry he's not really
angry he never loses his cool
he never stammers screams or even
improvises I haven't lost my temper in
40 years but pilgrim you caused a lot of
trouble this morning might have got
somebody killed and somebody got about
juin them out even at his worst he
doesn't lose that cool John Wayne
presence and there's actually something
amazing about that ability and I'm not
saying this makes him a bad actor
actually many studio Hollywood actors
had a limited vocal range whether
Humphrey Bogart was a private
investigator actually did shoot a
nightclub owner where I'm going you
can't follow what I've got to do you
can't be any part of or even an Irishman
I was hoping that maybe in the state of
mind you were in he wouldn't ride
tonight he always had his trademark
voice it explains why some actors at
that time are so easy to imitate you got
any girlfriends with the same problem
bring them over and John Wayne is no
exception
the John Wayne still seems to stand out
his complete control his whole persona
has an almost mythic quality to it so
you're a man's only good for one O's at
a time it's as if he's created a certain
idea for masculine authority through his
voice there's an idea of talking like
John Wayne but post-classical method
acting assured in a wave of chameleon
actors like Marlon Brando Robert De Niro
and Meryl Streep actors who morph to
their voices and disappeared into their
roles any attempt at imitating Daniel
day-lewis would probably result in
simply imitating one of his characters
not the actual actor because he does
them all so differently the use of
complex voice acting not only created
more immersive performances but actors
and directors now use voice in more
complicated ways to tell their story
it's not always about what a character
says but how and when they say it voice
shows a character's control of a scene
or
lack of control I want to use voice
acting as a means for analyzing one of
the most complicated characters in film
daniel plainview in there will be blood
and I think to understand daniel
plainview you have to first understand
talking like John Wayne
get off your horse alone John Wayne's
big break came in 1939 in stagecoach and
his introduction starts his streak of
vocal control right from the beginning
John Wayne has a mastery of voice after
a long montage of stagecoach riding he's
the one that can stop the entire
narrative with a single command and
notice what else is going on in his
introduction shot he immediately
establishes himself as a master of his
own movement through his flashy gun turn
the epic pushin of the camera toward his
face and the mythical quality of the
background like he manifested out of the
West
here we see confidence fearlessness and
mastery and the whole film stops to
accommodate him the remainder of the
scene presents another interesting
phenomenon in voice in 1939 editors were
still tinkering with how to cut dialogue
and the camera would stay on a character
most are all the time they were talking
except for John Wayne in this scene
you'll notice he's the only character
that talks while the camera focuses on
other characters as he talks it cuts to
reactions or he talks away from the
camera as he approaches the stagecoach
even in his first big movie even as
Ringo the kid and even right at his
character introduction his voice could
control the movement all on its own
he has an almost directorial influence
on the story there's a distinct power to
talking without being seen in the same
way that a narrator of a story has a
god-like quality to them if they talk
while not in viewed that means they're
still controlling the scene even when
they aren't there in John Wayne's
introductory scene we see two methods of
showing control directing the narrative
through voice and controlling the camera
and he's not the only one to control
this way please didn't you come to me
first we actually also hear Daniel
Plainview before we see him speaking
I've traveled over half off State
like John Wayne he shows narrative
control in his character introduction he
establishes he's the only one qualified
to drill and when people try to
interrupt his narrative he ignores them
what is your offer we're wasting time
yes please I do my own drilling his
authority does get challenged when the
crowd up roars but he simply leaves
changing the narrative to what he wants
refusing to not have total control
he even controls the movement of the
camera it stops when he stops it moves
when he moves after another voice of God
transition we see him got Elise how he
wants shifting the conversation to be
about family to win them over another
way to show control in a movie is
through controlling the voices of others
this can be as simple as regulating when
people talk or regulating what they're
allowed to say we associate what people
say with what they're thinking what they
believe in and what they want if you
control what someone can say you control
everything about them say my name in any
scene a character's voice can show
control in these factors how voice
directs the narrative how the voice
controls the shot and how characters
control the voices of others it's
usually a combination of the three in
reality everybody wishes they had the
control a voice like John Wayne even
when people disagree with him he still
drives the narrative and has complete
mastery of the world around him he may
sometimes be a flawed hero but the flaw
is never in his voice so he always has
some level of control in Red River he
gets betrayed but his voice makes it
clear that he'll end up with what he
wants every time you turn around expect
to see me but that's the problem with
John Wayne's Authority
it never gets questioned even when he
loses he still talks in that confident
air never completely losing his mastery
of the world of the West
what makes there will be blood so
well-written is how carefully each scene
tests power dynamics through voice and
Daniel Plainview's iconic presence does
get challenged in inventive ways to the
point where the film seems to question
whether or not a John Wayne like vocal
control is ever possible
even desired daniel plainview actually
gets a pretty worthy opponent in the
film eli sunday is a gifted orator and
he constantly questions Plainview's
vocal authority take a seemingly benign
conversation Plainview has with Eli
Sunday what appears to be Eli just
making a simple request is actually a
carefully coded fight for vocal control
Eli starts with some innocent chit chat
which Plainview doesn't engage in
spirits seem high then Eli chooses to
seat himself without being offered here
we see Eli taking initiative contrasting
his brothers politeness in an earlier
scene can I sit down please the scene
becomes about vocal control when Eli
asks to speak at the induction of the
well I will blush so well actually he
doesn't ask he says he will directing
the speech as he wants it before you
begin you should introduce me of course
Plainview correction but Eli ignores his
correction Derek you'll see me walk up
he even provides him a script and then
you could say the proud son of these
hills who tended his father's flock
Plainview Bates him letting him pick the
time well let's make it four o'clock
then and then it cuts to the actual
induction where Eli is supposed to speak
but Plainview directs it his way pulling
up the little girl and performing his
own script he does it all on his own
ignoring Eli's request the camera hovers
on Eli as Plainview blesses the well and
his voice of God dominates the scene and
Eli
he even manipulates Eli's words and
makes them his own number one name for
the lovely mr. every Sunday here by my
side Wow daughter of these hills in a
simple sequence Plainview gives up the
wind lets alized our town and gains back
control directing the moment how he
wanted controlling the camera and
controlling Eli's words but Eli
shouldn't be underestimated as a
character he speaks very well and is the
vocal leader of the town it's two
directors pitted against each other one
directs the congregation the other
directs the oil level the next vocal
showdown between the two comes in Eli's
territory when Plainview has to get
baptized notice he'll I already starts
in control when we hear his voice before
we see him speak I truly
everyone could be saved don't you he
directs when the congregation speaks of
course Plainview resists but Eli
subjugates him he has to respond as
directed by Eli what do you want me to
say
he life forces him to say exactly what
he wants and what he's insecure about I
have abandoned my child and in a
complete reversal Eli speaks as the
voice of God throughout while we focus
on Plainview it's a total opposite to
the last confrontation
Eli gives him the lines and he has to
recite them forcing Plainview to for the
first time lose his vocal control I've
abandoned my child I've abandoned my boy
the next time they see each other is at
the end of the movie even though Eli
asks for help in this scene he still
starts off in control the camera follows
him and he asserts himself by making
them drinks when Plainview agrees to
work with him he says he'll do it on one
condition I'd like you to tell me that
you are and have been both prophet the
God is a superstition and now Plainview
is the director again it is a superstar
in theory Plainview has bested him but
it doesn't really feel like a John Wayne
kind of local control I do
it's a bastardized version because at
the end Plainview wins but he's not in
control he spirals completely out of
control
towards the end he foams from the mouth
Sutter screams and grunts he loses
mastery of everything in this scene even
his walk when we think of John Wayne's
grace it's also in his walk
Plainview stumbles around in complete
erratic chaos he doesn't have control at
all another relationship that showcases
his lack of vocal control is with his
adopted son HW at first they work
together as partners but when he becomes
deaf they lose their ability to
communicate and in short Plainview
doesn't know what to do with him he's no
longer an asset to the company and
Plainview sends him away
years later HW returns with his
translator and planed he tries to
control him vocally by forcing him to
speak becoming threatened when he
considers HW a competitor you speak
instead of your little dog wolf all four
four four four forth so again he gets
vocal control but at what cost it's
cruel and doesn't feel like mastery and
a lot of what he says Daniel Plainview
may have the vocal influence but he's a
conman in one of his monologues he
elegantly talks about the schools he'll
build the wheat he'll grow in the
importance of family values but the
visual show only men and no schools
irrigation or farmland just people
preparing the drilling his voice of God
Authority tricks us even though
Plainview constantly talks about
bringing wealth to the town there are
actually very few signs of him improving
the town there's a sort of false sense
of control when he talks he vocally
controls Eli but not himself he can't
vocally control his son because he lost
his hearing but he tries anyway and he
can't control the work he does he has to
lie about the benefits of his drilling
and much of the dangers of work are out
of his control we expect plan to use
monologue to be true because narrators
are supposed to guide the story 1 John
Wayne movie that follows these
principles of narration is Red River
which has a monologue that's almost
identical to Plainview's if you replace
oil drilling with cattle good beef
hungry people
beep to make them strong bacon girl the
key difference though is that John
Wiggins hyper-masculine advertisement of
his cattle business is actually taken
seriously whereas there will be blood
codes playing view as a fraud John
Wayne's movies seem to have some
unrealistic ideals for Heroes whereas
there will be blood shows the more
sinister sides of being in control and I
know I said John Wayne always has vocal
control but even he loses it in some of
his later movies his chaotic shooting of
Buffalo sheds light on the darker side
to his supposed mastery regardless many
of his earlier films create an idea of a
hyper masculine male with complete
control of what they say and how they
say it there's a certain fantasy to
sounding like John Wayne but movies like
there will be blood bring into question
the validity of such a one-dimensional
kind of control having such vocal
Authority actually doesn't end well if
someone really had is mainly a dominion
over their world they wouldn't end up
like a cool suave John Wayne riding into
the sunset they'd probably become the
erratic miserable and lonely Daniel
Plainview because at the end of the day
the old western heroes aren't real that
level of mastery is not only unrealistic
but also dangerous
think about it why couldn't Daniel
Plainview have let Eli Sunday give that
speech what difference does it make if
he gave his little blessing Daniel
Plainview explains it himself I have a
competition I want no one else to
succeed and maybe that hyper-masculine
unfaltering thinking is no way to live
and no fantasy to strive towards when
studying voice John Wayne makes for a
great place to start his way of speaking
is hyperbolic and he represents the
ability to vocally master a seen his
purest vocal power however feels
unrealistic and dangerous when studying
more vocally complicated characters one
can use John Wayne's power as a starting
point and see how a character succeeds
in the John Wayne level of vocal control
and how they fail do they control the
camera do they control the narrative and
do they control others and also at what
cost thanks for watching this video is
brought to you by Skillshare Skillshare
has thousands of course is designed to
help you learn a new skill whether you
want to learn how to write or how to
create video they have some great
options for example if you want to start
writing take this course by author emily
gould that'll get you on the right track
if you want to start creating videos get
good
before investing in expensive equipment
check out natty Browns course on
low-budget filmmaking Ashley just signed
up for their After Effects for beginners
course because I want to incorporate it
into my YouTube videos so far it's been
super helpful Premium Membership begins
around $10 a month for unlimited access
to learning but the first 700 members
who click the link in the description
will get two months for free these spots
are going to go quickly so make sure to
be one of the first few